[Música]
[Aplausos]
un día y ve en el tráfico de la ciudad
escuchando mi estación de radio favorita
cuando comenzó a sonar un anuncio que
contaba que tan solo en la ciudad de
méxico cada año nacían y desaparecían
cerca de 10.000 bandas y proyectos
artísticos
este dato me dejó impactado me voló la
cabeza instantáneamente me puse a pensar
cuántos sueños cuánto esfuerzo cuánto
sacrificio de tiempo de recursos y
talentos se desperdiciaban cada año
también me puse hacer cuentas y si en
méxico una banda en promedio con
instrumentos entre guitarras bajo
batería y equipos de audio de mediana
calidad costará 30 mil pesos dejando de
lado horas de ensayo grabaciones y otras
cosas que son necesarias para promover
un proyecto aquellos que no logran
funcionar representarían al año cerca de
300 millones de pesos
es un montón de dinero aunado al valor
incalculable de talentos de miles de
jóvenes que si bien sabemos no todos
iban a terminar dedicándose a la música
muchos de ellos queriendo hacerlo
tendrían que dejar sus sueños de lado
entonces como le hace un artista para
que todo el esfuerzo que hace valga la
pena lo lleve a sonar en la radio o
ahora en las listas de reproducción de
las distintas plataformas digitales lo
lleve a tocar a mejores escenarios y así
logrará consolidar poco a poco una
carrera en la industria
a ver yo desde pequeño sabía que lo que
me apasionaba era la música pero pensaba
que como en muchas otras familias
mis papás muy probablemente no iban a
tener los recursos para enviarme a una
academia de música contemporánea como en
la que a mí verdaderamente me gustaría
estudiar en aquel entonces las
colegiaturas de esas escuelas rondaban
alrededor de los 10 mil pesos mensuales
y aunque existían ofertas para estudiar
música en la universidad pública yo no
me veía tocando música clásica sino rock
así que decidí conscientemente estudiar
otra carrera y elegí cual más la carrera
que había estudiado mi papá contaduría
en este momento ya se están preguntando
bueno entonces que hace un contador
hablándome de música
y es que es ahí donde muy probablemente
desde pequeños hemos creído que solo hay
un camino muy marcado y muy definido
para lograr las cosas y que todo lo
demás sale sobrando cuando uno es bueno
en lo que hace que solo es cuestión de
tiempo y de empeño de no quitar el dedo
del renglón y no dudo que existan
contadas excepciones que lo logren de
esa manera pero que hay de nosotros los
demás casi nada
casi nadie nos dice que en la mayoría de
las cosas que aprendemos hay
oportunidades invaluables para aumentar
significativamente el poder dedicarnos
con éxito a aquello que más nos hace
felices aquello que verdaderamente nos
apasiona
por ejemplo
seguramente todos conocemos al niño que
quiere ser futbolista ya saben de quién
estoy hablando y que a la hora del
recreo mete muchos goles pero que va
probando una clase de matemáticas porque
cree que no va a ocupar las matemáticas
en su vida ni le van a ser útiles para
su carrera profesional al final solo
tiene según él que tener talento con el
balón con el balón
otro ejemplo es el chico que se la pasa
tocando la guitarra todos los días pero
se salta sus clases de inglés y por eso
la mamá lo regaña y le pone como castigo
que no puede tocar más y en días o en
semanas hasta que que hasta que mejore
sus calificaciones yo les preguntaría y
si lo estamos haciendo mal y si existe
una manera más fácil de lograr dedicarte
a lo que más te gusta y si te digo que
te puedes ahorrar un montón de castigos
de discusiones y malos ratos tratando de
convencer a otros que te den una
oportunidad en lo que más te gusta que
te den una oportunidad en la música
por ello en esta charla yo quiero
compartirles algunas de las cosas que a
mí me funcionaron para lograrlo
una de ellas me sucedió estando en la
escuela cuando estaba en clases nos
llega una convocatoria y nos dice si
tienes buen promedio puedes ganar una
beca
y yo dije una beca no suena nada mal
para que podría ocupar una beca
con un montón de cosas fíjense yo ya
estaba súper cerca del promedio que
solicitaban para poder aplicar así que
cuando lo medité un poco me cae el
veinte y lo vi con claridad dije solo
tengo que poner un poquito de un poquito
más de esfuerzo de lo que ya ponía de
todas maneras yo ya me levantaba
temprano todos los días ya viajaba más
de dos horas diario para llegar a la
escuela
qué más daba si estando allí le ponía un
poquito de empeño un poquito más de
empeño
lo que a mí realmente me animaba es que
con ello con esa beca si a mí me le
otorgaban yo podría comprarme mi primera
computadora le iba a poder pagar en
pagos chiquitos con eso que iba sacando
de la beca pero podría tener una
computadora lo que más me entusiasmaba
es que por fin iba a poder grabar mis
primeras canciones aunque claro yo les
decía a mis papás que iba a ser para mis
tareas escolares lo cual no era falta
todo ese esfuerzo pronto rindió más
frutos
mis papás veían que cumplía con mi deber
de bien en la escuela entonces no me
molestaban cuando estaba súper clavado
haciendo mis primeros demos al contrario
se mostraban interesados porque querían
escuchar aquello que yo iba creando me
echaban porras fueron mis primeros fans
he de confesar que tengo unas papas
súper buena onda y que al verme todos
los días entre tareas y mis canciones en
el momento en el que me atreví a pedirle
su apoyo para comprar mi primera
guitarra eléctrica también en pagos
chiquitos ellos no solamente accedieron
sino que me la regalaron wow este plan
estaba funcionando
lo que quiero resaltar de esta
experiencia es que somos nosotros los
que muchas veces nos ponemos el pie
y nos peleamos con quienes podrían ser
nuestros primeros fans y más fervientes
seguidores
no estoy bromeando en lugar de
enfrascarnos en pleitos con nuestros
papás nuestras mamás o nuestros maestros
que seamos honestos no vamos a ganar y
créanme que lo he intentado es mejor
volver los nuestros aliados porque
créanme que así la vida se vuelve mucho
mucho más fácil
cuando estaba por terminar la
universidad y después de haberme probado
en distintos proyectos musicales en la
escuela he echado a perder un montón de
canciones que seguro no querrían
escuchar en este momento conformamos la
primera banda profesional comisario
pantera
y desde ese entonces las primeras
decisiones que fueron super importantes
las decisiones que tomamos desde mi
punto de vista hicieron una gran
diferencia
les voy a contar que lo primero que
hicimos fue comprar una camioneta entre
todos para poder irnos de gira por todo
el país con un artista que era mucho más
famoso que nosotros que nos abrió las
puertas eventualmente para ser una banda
reconocida con una banda emergente a
nivel nacional porque la gira era por
todo el país yo les cuento esto porque
esta idea se me ocurrió gracias a mi
formación universitaria como contador
como financiero que me dio una
perspectiva diferente me mostró que era
mucho más beneficioso en ese momento
invertir en un equipo de transporte para
irnos de gira que en mejorar nuestros
instrumentos como muchos de nuestros
amigos lo estaban haciendo
yo iba a seguir tocando igual de mal con
una guitarra cara que con la guitarra
que ya tenía pesa baja entonces está
dispuesto a hacer ese sacrificio para mí
era una inversión
algo que iba a rendir más frutos a
futuro en un primer instante les
confieso que mis compañeros no
estuvieron para nada de acuerdo porque
para ellos como para muchos otros
músicos lo lógico era comprar nuevos
instrumentos más profesionales o ropa
para vernos mejor y no una camioneta sin
embargo a vogue para que los pocos
recursos que hemos contado juntando los
invirtiéramos finalmente en ella fue
cuando me di cuenta que si no hubiese
estudiado mi carrera universitaria lo
más probable es que yo también hubiese
seguido el mismo camino y hubiese
preferido gastar el dinero en algo menos
provechoso para el futuro de este
proyecto hoy en día sé que todas estas
decisiones permitieron que un proyecto
que parecía un sueño salido de un pueblo
recóndito en la ciudad de méxico-
recóndito pero hermoso se convirtiera en
una forma de vida y que al final haber
estudiado una carrera tradicional en
lugar de volverse una gran pérdida de
tiempo como muchos pudieron pensar
en múltiples ventajas para saber cómo
administrar mejor los recursos que
genera vamos como dirían nuestras mamás
cómo hacer rendir mejor el dinero
ese que nos pagaban por tocar cómo
entender mejor un contrato cómo lograr
mejores condiciones e inclusive la
posibilidad de ayudar a otros artistas
amigos míos con mis conocimientos
es verdad que desde pequeño uno se
siente más cercano a ciertas actividades
y materias pero me parece algo valioso
de recalcar
el saber apreciar que todos los
conocimientos que vamos adquiriendo a lo
largo de nuestra vida nos sirven y que
incluso muchas veces nos permiten tomar
mejores decisiones
para finalizar
quiero compartirles tres cosas que
nos ayudarán que te ayudarán una vez que
identifiques lo que te apasiona la
primera es que utilices todos los
conocimientos que se esté brinden a tu
favor la segunda es que todos los logros
son fruto del esfuerzo y de la
disciplina y la tercera es ser más
estratégico más inteligente construye
verdadera red de apoyo no ahuyente a las
personas que pueden ser tus más grandes
aliados logra que la gente crea en ti y
te apoye otra cosa que es fundamental
tomar en cuenta es que muchas veces
creemos que las personas talentosas son
así desde el nacimiento yo pienso en mis
ídolos en paul mccartney en michael
jackson en josé alfredo jiménez en juan
gabriel y hasta se me eriza la piel de
pensar en los talentosos que son en todo
lo que logran transmitir con su música y
en sus conciertos sin embargo algo que
he aprendido a lo largo de estos años
tanto con mi banda como con mi proyecto
solista y viendo las carreras de
diferentes colegas es que se requiere
mucha disciplina
y esfuerzo por supuesto que estar sobre
un escenario y ver que las personas se
identifican con mis canciones es un
sentimiento de felicidad indescriptible
pero para poder llegar a eso para sentir
esa alegría y plenitud hay muchas horas
de trabajo duro
de todos los días de ensayos e incluso
de conflictos entre compañeros al final
la música es mucho más que talento
[Aplausos]
[Música]